la defensa del tenista novak djokovic
revela que la extensión médica que le
fue otorgada para ingresar a australia
se debe a que contrajo kobe de 19 en
diciembre ahora la polémica gira en
torno a los eventos en los que participó
el deportista en esos momentos el
gobierno serbio le extendió todo su
apoyo
tras dos años y medio en una prisión
egipcia llegó a francia el activista
propalestino rami hat quien había sido
arrestado por su supuesta colaboración
con una organización islámica acusada de
terrorista por el gobierno egipcio para
ser liberado tuvo que renunciar a la
ciudadanía de ese país africano
reina una inquietante calma en
kazajistán tras la disposición del
presidente casi me toca ayer de disparar
a matar y sin advertencia una orden que
frenó las multitudinarias
manifestaciones de almaty que dejaron
decenas de muertos pero que no calmó el
descontento ciudadano
actualizamos las principales noticias
del día en francés en 24 yo soy daniel
hablando la comenzamos con una
actualización del caso del tenista
serbio novak djokovic quien enfrenta a
un nuevo obstáculo en su lucha por
entrar a disputar el abierto de
australia a pesar de que sus abogados
presentaron pruebas de que había dado
positivo para kobe del 19 el 16 de
diciembre un vídeo de ese día lo muestra
en un evento público en belgrado sin
llevar mascarilla andrés granadillo nos
amplia en medio de la incertidumbre y la
polémica el tenista novak djokovic
recibe el respaldo del gobierno serbio
que ha dicho estar haciendo todo lo
posible para que la estrella del deporte
pueda competir en el abierto australiano
el gobierno de la república de serbia
entregará todas las garantías sobre
novak
estamos listos para hacer lo necesario
para que les sea permitido entrar a
australia todos
elpresidente aleksandar vucic está
personalmente involucrado la ministra de
relaciones exteriores de australia
anunció que nuestros mensajes le serán
transmitidos al ministro interior y que
los hechos serán presentados en la corte
que se encargará de tomar una decisión
el lunes nosotros seguimos en la lucha
en las calles de belgrado las protestas
a su favor se mantienen por tercer día
consecutivo mostrando que el apoyo a la
estrella del tenis por parte de sus
seguidores sigue intacto y no va que
está en nuestros corazones que el señor
lo proteja a él ya no está serbios
esperamos que la justicia prevalezca y
que el lunes nos reunamos aquí con un
epílogo diferente para celebrar su
libertad
para poder ingresar australia se exigen
pruebas de esquemas completos de
vacunación pero djokovic presentó una
exención por haber dado positivo al cob
y 19 6 de diciembre según se conoció
este sábado cuando sus abogados
mostraron el diagnóstico pero su
veracidad podría estar en entredicho ese
mismo día djokovic fue filmado
recorriendo la sede de belgrado en la
oficina nacional de correos de serbia
que él honró a él ya su carrera con el
lanzamiento de una serie de estampillas
mientras su situación se resuelve
djokovic sigue confinado en un hotel de
detención de emigrantes en melbourne
donde espera que inicie el desafío legal
por la cancelación de su visa este lunes
en el tribunal federal del circuito al
solo a una semana de que inicie el
torneo
y en noticias de francia el activista
egipcio palestino ramis at aterrizó en
este país tras ser puesto en libertad en
egipto allí llevaba 900 días encarcelado
bajo sospecha de colaborar con los
hermanos musulmanes una organización
islamista acusada de terrorista por el
presidente egipcio abdel fattah al cis y
rodrigo sedano tiene los detalles
un abrazo en parís entre el activista
egipcio palestino rami saad y su esposa
el primero tras 900 días de cautiverio
en egipto tras lo que ongs como amnistía
internacional declararon en 2019 como
una detención arbitraria cual ayer
slater dos años y medio después sigo
teniendo toda mi determinación y mi
firmeza para continuar sigo mi camino a
él existen insiste en liberar a mis
amigos y mis compañeros de las cárceles
egipcias
insisto en los derechos humanos en
egipto
insisto en una palestina libre insiste
en for a free palestine hijo de nabil
shaath importante político palestino y
asesor presidencial de mahmud abás es
miembro activo del movimiento a favor
del boicot contra israel a su llegada a
parís quiso dar las gracias a enmanuel
macrón y a otros dirigentes franceses
por sus esfuerzos para la liberación el
presidente galo se congratuló en redes
sociales celebró la decisión de las
autoridades egipcias de liberar a rami
sad comparto el alivio de su esposa cell
y lebron que se encuentra en francia y
con quien nos hemos reunido gracias a
todos los que desempeñaron un papel
positivo en este feliz resultado en
egipto fue acusado de tener vínculos con
los hermanos musulmanes una hermandad
islamista calificada como terrorista por
el presidente abdel fattah al sisi según
el gobierno egipcio junto a ellos habría
intentado provocar violencia y
disturbios de charles whitman items me
acusaron de muchas cosas y un día me
dijeron estás acusado de formar parte de
una organización terrorista
y yo le pregunté al tipo cuál era la
organización terrorista me dijo bueno no
te lo vamos a decir ok antes de salir en
libertad se tuvo que renunciar a su
ciudadanía egipcia según denunció su
familia en un comunicado
y cáceres kazajistán parece retornar a
la calma después de las manifestaciones
violentas que dejaron decenas de muertos
algunos a manos de las fuerzas de
seguridad muchos abandonaron las calles
después de que el gobierno de kashin
tokáyev reconociera haber ordenado
dispararles a matar a quienes causaron
disturbios ahora los residentes de
almaty la ciudad principal de este país
luchan por encontrar alimentos y
combustibles- después de días de caos
coches quemados y edificios calcinados
un inquietante calma ha vuelto a las
calles de almaty la principal ciudad de
kazajistán tras la represión del
gobierno contra los participantes en las
protestas con el humo aún saliendo de
las oficinas las fuerzas de seguridad-
casacas patrullan las calles junto a las
tropas rusas las instrucciones del
presidente disparan a matar si es
necesario kashin toca jets calificó a
los manifestantes de bandidos
influenciados por potencias extranjeras
en redes sociales dijo que estaba en
marcha una operación antiterrorista para
restablecer la ley y el orden los
residentes de la ciudad siguen divididos
sobre las posturas del gobierno aquí
creo que el estado les dará algunas
concesiones alguna ayuda porque nuestra
gente vive una vida pobre
esto no empezó hoy y no terminará hoy si
nuestro respetado presidente no toma las
decisiones correctas las protestas
comenzaron por el alza de los precios
del combustible y se extendieron
rápidamente por toda la nación la
frustración por el autoritarismo es
generalizada así como las malas
condiciones de vida a pesar de los
abundantes recursos naturales de
kazajistán
ante las mayores protestas desde la
independencia de moscú hace tres décadas
el presidente toca jr pidió ayuda al
kremlin más de 70 aviones militares
rusos han llegado desde el jueves las
tropas rusas se retomaron el control del
aeropuerto y se cree que han ayudado a
las fuerzas de seguridad kazajas a
sofocar la revuelta pero con las
comunicaciones cortadas o bloqueadas en
gran medida en todo el país la represión
permanece tras un espeso velo de
incertidumbre
y al menos 16 turistas murieron tras
enfrentarse a temperaturas bajo cero
después de que miles de ellos quedaran
varados en sus vehículos en el norte de
pakistán a unos 1000 vehículos aún
siguen atrapados en la estación del
cerro al noreste de la capital islamabad
debido a las fuertes nevadas se han
desplegado pelotones del ejército para
ayudar a la administración civil en las
operaciones de rescate
en colombia la guerrilla del eln ee se
adjudicó el atentado contra agentes del
escuadrón antidisturbios de la policía
en la ciudad de cali en el ataque 13
uniformados resultaron heridos dos de
ellos de gravedad- el gobierno
colombiano ofreció una millonaria
recompensa por información que permita
la captura de los autores materiales así
como de alias 'el rolo' líder de este
grupo subversivo quien sería el autor
intelectual del atentado
y al menos de seis personas perdieron la
vida 32 resultaron heridas y otras 20
permanecen desaparecidas luego de que
una pared de roca cayera sobre varias
lanchas turísticas en el lago furnas en
el estado brasileño de minas gerais la
piedra que formaba parte del cañón cayó
desde una altura de 5 metros sobre tres
embarcaciones dos de ellas naufragaron
totalmente los bomberos señalaron que el
desprendimiento pudo deberse a las
precipitaciones de los últimos días
y finalizamos en el espacio porque tras
dos semanas desde su lanzamiento el
telescopio espacial james webb ya se
encuentra completamente desplegado la
última maniobra fue realizada con éxito
su enorme espejo principal de 65 metros
se extendió completamente james webb es
el observatorio astronómico más grande y
poderoso que jamás haya salido del
planeta y buscará la luz tenue de las
primeras estrellas y galaxias agua y
otros posibles indicios de vida
y así terminamos este resumen
informativo con las noticias más
relevantes de la jornada de este sábado
24 también puede vernos en france 24
punto com
[Música]